rst Ladyship
was really a transition
from the old and the new
versions of womanhood.
(upbeat music)
- Lou Hoover was not only
considered a tough woman,
she was an intellect.
- She was actually one
of the very first women
in the country to
hold a geology degree.
- She had met another person
interested in geology,
and his name was Herbert Hoover.
- Eventually her purposed
marriage and she accepted.
Soon after, his mining company
transferred him to China.
They took a steamer there
from their honeymoon.
She learned Mandarin Chinese.
- When she and her
husband were in China,
they got caught up
right in the middle of
the Boxer Rebellion.
- This was a violent Chinese
Nationalist uprising.
- She was more concerned
about getting food and aid
to the other individuals in the
compound that they lived in,
more so than her own safety.
She literally got on a
bicycle and carried things
as bullets were
flying back and forth.
One of bullets hit the
spoke of the bicycle
that she was riding on.
She lived through
that, survived it.
She just carried on.
Lou Hoover loved the outdoors.
And she was not afraid of
being athletic as well.
- She was Vice President of
the Women's Amateur
Athletic Association.
She thought that girls
participating in sport,
being outside, getting
exercise, could be tremendously
beneficial for their physical
and emotional wellbeing.
She was also very involved
with the Girl Scouts.
She was national President of
the Girl Scouts in the 1920s
and then Honorary President
when she was First Lady.
- She believed that the
mission of the Girl Scouts
was helpful to
the entire nation.
She believed strongly
that girls and women
should be educated.
That girls and women should
take part in the body politic.
- She often time used her
role with the Girl Scouts
as a way to kind of
reach American women
and American girls and teach
them how they could help out
their communities
during the Depression.
- Lou Henry Hoover had
a strong sense of self.
So when the time
came as First Lady
to invite all the congressional
wives to the White House,
she decided she would do
that even though one of the
congressional wives
was African American.
- There was a congressman
named Oscar De Priest
and he was the first
African American congressman
to be elected in
the 20th century.
A black person
hadn't be entertained
at the White House in decades.
But Lou Hoover was adamant
that Mrs. De Priest
be invited on an equal
basis with the other members
of Congress' wives.
- She made a point of
meeting Jessie De Priest
at the front door, of shaking
Mrs. De Priest's hand,
of welcoming her
into the White House.
When the firestorm
of controversy hit
after Mrs. De Priest was
there, as she knew it would,
Mrs. Hoover ignored it.
- A number of
Southern legislatures
actually censured Mrs. Hoover.
They passed resolutions
condemning her having
invited an African American
woman to the White House.
She was hurt by the criticism
but she never
regretted doing it.
(upbeat music)